[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Michael says
[Applause]
so enjoy everyone
Chris will be here soon when he finishes
signing
but everybody's
everybody's here who's still getting
autographs already
half of all of us thank you so much what
an incredible weekend this has been and
you're all amazing thank you thank you
they gave two microphones for four
actors that's like one banana for a
thousand monkeys
well thank you all for being
for me
um I had a Russian for all of you sorry
that Rick couldn't be here yet but
first of all I would like to know if you
guys meet each other regularly other
than a conveyed Nations
Terrell and I go for lunches and dinners
and cry and laugh a lot
and Michael and I see each other but you
know Joe and Ben live in Los Angeles so
actually Amanda keeps asking me to get
off her front patio
it's because you've been living there
for some time now
okay and my second question would be
which was your favorite scene or the
scene you most remember from Stargate
franchise whether it was a funny scene
or maybe a more solemn scene
apparently it was the scene they cut
where I held hands with Amanda
my favorite scenes who all didn't get a
chance to see because it all happened
behind backstage where do you remember
what was the one in that Glass Castle 20
what was it
we lost it it was late at night do you
remember we had the giggles and we
couldn't stop oh my gosh they started to
get mad at us because then they had to
keep retouching our makeup because we
were sobbing we were laughing so hard
and Christopher was in that really hot
role when he was pissed
um
Dom DeLuise when he came to the show uh
I mean I'm amazed that they actually
were able to hobble together an episode
where we weren't laughing crying through
it because he was just such a phenomenal
man
um yeah remember
we were just talking backstage about the
Stargate actors that we lost and uh so I
you know obviously have very fond
memories of working with Carmen and we
all Michael just said before we came
ready because you know what feels wrong
about this Don's not here
yeah yeah
sorry sadness
I think
as Terrell said that we probably view
things more off camera than on screening
so your memories are watching the show
you are on screen ideas of like oh was
that fun to shoot
95 of our life occurs when the camera's
not rolling so there's so much activity
going on behind it and there's a lot of
crazy stuff but I do remember one of the
more satisfying moments was when
I was doing an episode where Jason was
here and Rachel was here and it was very
simple she just had to punch Jason
in the face and when you do it there's
film tricks you know you create like
this much distance but you shoot over
the shoulder so it looks like you're
hitting and I'm in the middle and
she does this and she makes solid
contact
and I watched Jason's nose just get
bigger
and Blood start coming out and I'm like
this is genius
please don't yell cut because a lot of
times directors you'll cut if
something's going wrong I'm like please
and they kept it it was beautiful
my name is so many seasons I mean I
didn't get to work very much with Daryl
but we did get to do an episode called
Lifeboat and one of my favorite you know
my favorite myths that we did was
actually off camera Richard had um his
father had passed away during filming
and so he had to go away to the funeral
and look after things there and he came
back late in the filming after Terrell
and I had already done all of our scenes
and so in order to do uh off camera for
him deloise just said Peter DeLuise just
said just
just do all your seeds just get through
the whole thing so Terrell and I did
this entire one act play
for about 15 minutes strains of just all
of our scenes run together so we had
this entire like little you know one act
going while Richard watched and reacted
to it and it was because you know
everything so stopped started it was
actually the most fun it was like doing
our own theater piece so it was uh it
was fantastic and we hadn't gotten a
chance to work together so much so that
was probably the the best yeah
thank you very much
[Applause]
I I also have a question for all of you
um there was this episode unending when
some of you were on the ship you had you
were in normal time and outside where uh
were slowly more slowly than
in the ship so you spend a lot of time
till you get old and then more purchase
died and so so if you had a long time
what would you do
um what you never did because you didn't
have time for it and yes
foreign
language or playing piano or something
like that
I'd memorize the entire internet
I
really want to say but I shouldn't we
have more sex but
I mean Carter learned to pay Play The
Cello which was kind of fun but yeah I'd
probably just read everything I could
get my hands on and sex
[Applause]
that answer is too good
I'd like to be a cello
thank you
thanks for being here
here's a question and if you could go to
a weird Stargate would you do it and who
would you take with you
[Applause]
thank you
yeah I I'd go through the Stargate but
I I would definitely go through the
store again
multiple cellos
foreign
space and they asked us what we were
having what we would bring with us and
ironically I brought a Johnny Cash
poster
but I originally said I should have a
Distillery
I thought that was genius because you
know match they had that I was like
but they put the kai watch on that but
that's what I would have done I would
have brought alcohol making material
anything but Ben Roeder
[Applause]
okay
thank you
one of my favorite episodes is the time
and then it always asks a question if
alsoever actually a scene where Richard
ended and doesn't answer that
hey
if the answer is the cello
what what was the question that was out
in an episode called time
Loop episode
the question that Rick asked Daniel or
the Daniel answers is that what you're
is that is like
um it's window of opportunity
[Applause]
to answer them
no
that's what you call taking the long way
around all right
[Music]
that's pretty cool that you guys are
here
do you guys miss portraying your
characters
oh yes
because I took a staff blast to the
chest
and Michael got to
were you in a sarcophagus
how did you come back
which sign
do I do I miss playing the character
I miss the people that we worked with
more than I miss playing the character
to be honest I I had a I had a good time
uh yeah I miss it and I I miss Sam she's
pretty cool but it like Ben said I
missed the camaraderie there's something
you know when we finished the last
episode and all sort of whipped our eyes
out and walked away the next day just
felt so weirdly empty because it was
like I'm not going to see these people
every day and
what am I going to do when I wake up at
five in the morning
uh so yeah definitely definitely miss it
I didn't think I missed playing my
character until we did this uh AI Zoom
reading and we got to play with each
other uh and as crazy as and Play The
Cello he is
script was I mean it was nonsense
um it was still kind of half written in
character and so you hear the voices
again made me go oh I miss this [__] I
miss these people so yeah I guess I do
yeah I definitely miss playing the
character
um my accountant misses me playing that
uh I think my now ex-wife missed me
going there to play that character
uh
and so yeah I would go back
Heather
um I.T Tech teach technology to children
so something that the students often ask
me is uh why do we have like such pieces
of equipment and what are their uses and
things like that
um you guys have to work with an awful
lot of props or technology that was both
present day and it's futuristic and so
there was one really useful piece of
star game technology that you would want
to be real
could you tell me what that was
the healing device and healing device
yeah for sure I wish that was real
on everyone
I would say the gate I mean can you
imagine having that portal to go
wherever you wanted to go I that would
be it for sure
no airport security that's right
yeah for sure the game
not the chubby
well I'll tell you what I wouldn't worry
what was it ridiculous gun that is
shaped like a penis
what the hell was that the first time
they handed me that I was like
something clean
it's ridiculous
um but um
Jason's character had this absurdly
large gun that killed Wraith
I have no idea what the technology was
but I was like I want that and they
wouldn't give it to me
so that's what I would think
as much as I hated the zap guns
um that's what I would want because I
would there's so many people I would
walk around stunning
foreign
and sometimes I just want to make router
disappear
let's look to see the camaraderie
[Applause]
thanks very much thank you
hi
um as everybody else it's great to see
you guys here and I apologize to my girl
but I have a question just for Ben
and
I apologize to everybody else it's a
participation yeah
[Applause]
yesterday you talked about basically
bullying them into bringing back critin
by just playing as you as not quite
sorry Scorpius
uh Harvey yes yes
and uh so you basically got Wayne some
extra work did he ever give you beer
outfit for that or was he too upset to
have to go back in the makeup chair for
ages no I think he owes me some money
doesn't he
uh yeah but Craig went insane in season
two and it was a lot of fun yeah it was
fine but I we did an episode where I was
hallucinating the bad guy
and then immediately after that episode
I said just so you guys know I'm
hallucinating him all the time
so I would be in the middle of a scene
where I'm just talking I could shop
stop and I would do it in a way they
couldn't cut
oh we're going to water and I would just
stop it you know walking talking I would
do this and I told the writers that oh
yeah no I'm hallucinating the bad guy
all the time and then we can't do that
you can't do that and then but about
five episodes later the executive dude
goes I got it you're hallucinating
Scorpius all the time
and so they created this character which
crite called Harvey which only he saw
which we were able to bring the bad guy
in and we'd have these amazing scenes
with this actor Wayne pyram that I kind
of forced it on him but I never did that
on Stargate I just did what everybody
told me to do and all I know is that I
never said he directed that whole answer
to you as the you have some experience
hallucinating or something
right now
I tried to do some stuff to Mike but
it's just
it's like a mirror
thank you thank you
[Applause]
hi this is a question for Amanda for all
the shippers in the episode divide and
conquer we saw where you were playing to
be later we saw the statement of Jack
but the retest thing that he cares a lot
more than he's supposed to for Sam we
never saw the same statement so what do
you think she would have said
should care about me
[Applause]
said this in chemistry and yeah would
have absolutely been the safety of that
okay
sir thank you
[Applause]
Okay so
[Music]
as
and I want to ask when you meet parents
where are some stories we got an epic on
you and how you play your roles after
that
[Music]
on you
memories about you
sir you're asking do the fans have an
impact on us yeah
yeah
I want this yeah
interacting with people the audience the
people who are accepting your work has a
huge impact
um we as much as we work in dark sheds
it doesn't mean anything unless it
reaches an audience and the audience is
the final order of our work if you're in
the theater it's the same thing so no
it's everything
it's it's the it's the payoff for a
lifetime pretending to be someone you're
not when the audience
takes your work in and it means
something to them
[Applause]
I honestly I think you nailed it that's
the perfect answer because that's
exactly what it is
yeah I've been getting to hear your
stories and tidbits of your personal
lives and the fact that you share it
with us is
and today I'm sure we wear our last
aren't you guys tired it's like now we
get so much energy from all of you that
yeah it's just a real difference
all the time
no
no not at all
thanks
my question is if you had to choose
where would you like to work in Atlantis
through sjsc or on the ship of the
Stargate command
the characters are us personally you
personally if it was real
D all of the above
I almost feel like this is a trick
question
just because
still get to go off on adventures but
you get to go home and walk your dog at
night
just like yeah everybody's giving these
great answers
um completely at the at the at the base
for sure because yeah we get to well I
live there pretty much but
um just to be with our friends and still
do what we do that that would be a good
place I'd want to be
Ben yeah the SGC Colorado Springs is a
great town
you should visit see the gate
hi there
unfortunately Rick is in here yeah but
I'm going tofu facility request
um David blue asked me on Twitter David
blue who played Elia on University asked
me give my love to Ben Michael Amanda
and Audi a so that's Tom and I was
wondering
um did you really get to know each other
during a few times on the side of the
universe
or did you actually connect to each
other afterwards and conventions you are
turning together and especially to men
since you were banned on universe of the
world
what's your connection to navy blue and
of course feel free to send your love
back to David because I'm sure some
people you are filming it
plus you gave in
um David was really interesting because
he he was a fan like he really loved
Stargate and so it was always such a joy
to talk to him because he was so happy
to be there and yeah he was yeah he's
lovely
we didn't get a lot of time together
Dave was at my house recently so I think
we like him
love you love you David
I I met David uh first time in
Australian convention and uh we we
um we texted our way through covet
together
and facetimed
thank you
[Applause]
hey guys I'm Marina
um and I talked to the question I just
want to say thank you to you to the
whole series because I watched 10 years
ago and third series I met my husband I
met the love of my life and he's sitting
in one of the rows
raise your hand
and now we are around eight years
together in four years married
yes
I'm a chicken cemento shipper and I
found out that we have around the same
age difference than both of them so
around 18 years
I was born in 92 and he's 75 born
so you're saying it would have worked
out
yes
[Applause]
thank you so much for giving me this guy
is that like oh there it goes come on
man you gotta keep up
any events on what your characters wear
outside of the mountain or Atlantis
no
no I think you if you were asking did we
have any
um
uh say in what the characters wore off
face
[Applause]
yeah
she had a really great costume designer
Christina mcquarie who knew us all so
well and kind of
oh ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
sorry anyway
I apologize to all of you for my
cardiness but you're used to it by an
hour yes we are
higher right
did you have any influence over with me
suddenly he's an emcee I love to just be
influence over what your character wore
outside of the mountain when your
character went you know
of course you did
you came to work in yeah whenever I
slept in that night
well I I don't even remember what an
award to be honest
probably maybe it didn't look like it
fit yes there wasn't mine yeah
um such a question it's so personal
um
yeah I suppose they did I didn't matter
really I mean I don't mean to see
Cavaliers yes I do I didn't care what I
wore it was all about the character the
anime
I heard some pictures of it
no I didn't have any influence at all
but I would just say yes or not
thank you sure thank you
[Applause]
oh
hi there
um yeah
and my question is
like the
they try to move Origins
and Star Trek did a two in the past
um is there any chance or any plan that
you play together again universe
well I'll say something okay right I
would give my left arm to be
right-handed
um I I've been thinking about that uh
well never but um
but in doing the little thing that we
did with AI script with Brad such I got
to grill him on it he said it's off his
hands but I personally would do anything
to work again with this group
[Applause]
yeah I don't in terms of what's
happening with the franchise if that's
some sort of way of digging it that we
have no idea and we don't think Brad has
been contacted and uh
tried or he keeps in the conversation
going occasionally it gets a little
annoying on the other end where just so
you know we're not going to make a show
because you keep bugging us
um and I believe it's not MGM anymore or
yeah
the studios but something's in the way
of getting production and getting some
money to start writing and doing that
stuff that's
well it's almost always the promises
money but
um I don't know I think it would work
because O'Neill is an old fart
could be me
we've changed a bit
it used to be like hey how was your
weekend what clip did you go to and then
it was hey how was your weekend how are
the kids now it's like how's your
prostate I said
thank you
I don't know let me check
[Applause]
foreign
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
hello big fan still re-watching the
series again and again continuously so
that's a quick following up question
if you get the heart removed
which authors would you like to see
playing your roles two constraints wrong
answers only and no music instruments
who would we like to play our characters
if it wasn't us yeah who got that from
that
when she said I was doing the
Translating around here
with me
doctor would you have played you if it
wasn't you right that's the question in
our own life story is that what you're
talking about yeah
if you go get and you start get serious
they have to reboot so the same story
about new actors
which which ones you're asking the
actors how they want to be replaced
surely a rambling for me
thank you
um James Mayer
[Applause]
Ben Rogers
[Music]
I mean cards working so let's just do
O'Neill
[Music]
[Applause]
see I told you I had to explain this
stay close
you know does anyone watch Wellington
paranormal this little crazy taikoi TV
show that yeah the cop in that
is really really funny she'd make a
great murder she's like pistol
if she's that tall she should play me
again
[Applause]
I'm so desperately want to think we're
Irreplaceable
thank you
while I have it I might as well
advertise it
it's going fast
and probably you're still standing there
maybe wanting more of an answer was that
satisfactory or yes awesome thank you
all right
[Applause]
um I've got two questions actually for
me
um first off if you had to and you had
no choice
um you would could move to any planet
and any culture scene at the started
universe but you could not go back which
of it would be
what planet would we go to
and if we could not come back yes but
that's ourselves
as opposed to
yes
in real life
without any plans in mind kids
p3x789
it's a non-binary planet
um
we never actually saw where they lived
that would have been kind of fun what
planets are there the ones that we know
which one you like that each one in the
early Seasons the planet where we went
to hell because we're all going to end
up there anyway
so I live in Planet Vancouver with all
those green trees so I'd stay there
I was probably go to a planet where
Janet is still alive
whoa
[Applause]
not Florida
I personally don't remember all the
planets we went to
at all
um but they all mysteriously look like
Vancouver
and I think there was one planet that um
was Richard kindly I was Richard kind
the actor
so it was like a planet of like funny
people
and maybe I'd go to funny people land
or maybe that's the hell he's talking
about I'm not sure
can I ask the second question I [__]
yourself up okay how would you react
right now if the target was real
[Applause]
obviously not well
we got nothing here
well it takes time to train to go
through that thing
as I recall
it's cold I
what are you talking about
don't we all end up in Giza anyway
look at me throwing stuff out like
that like I know the show
um
what was the question
that's the only way we got that I think
I think we touched on that one
excuse me she's shaking her head no
we're saying that's all you're gonna get
[Applause]
thank you
the games tonight it's Canada against
Germany yeah
that was yesterday's news don't rub it
in
hello everyone
um I got a question that I got a
question for all of you
um it's a more grounded technical
question
um
I actually I
[Applause]
thank you
maybe it's not so bad as you expect
I just want to know how sound the star
gets unset
and we all knew the sounds of the
Stargate on Film on the series but how
does it sound in real life does it does
it make squeaky noises or does it does
any sound at all what can you tell us
about the sounds of the sand
yeah but like it actually in the gate
actually spun and locked on to different
Chevrons so that's you know that made a
sound
and there's the uh the sound of the CO2
so I'll just let the CO2 you do the
sound of the sound
[Music]
but they were on the analog set
we went
it's very quiet
okay that that was my follow-up question
if the uh Atlantis Stargate summoned
other and then the Stargate in the
chayat mountain
sounded more expensive
okay thank you thanks
hi again
so I have a question for Rick another
question for all of you
um so first one is one
my t-shirt says in 1988 maccabouts or he
was vegetarians today in MacGyver would
be vegan so don't you think it would be
cool because you talked about
that you're asking dogs in real life
what if MacGyver would have a sanctuary
for animals with his family his kids
obviously he has a son and a daughter
and he could have rescued around a fix
stuff and cut his fingers off or not
and take care of his hair
awesome
slow down
go through this point by point
in 88
MacGyver was vegetarian would he be
vegan now
do you remember that part
he has no recollection of this
for the sake of conversation I will say
yes of course
well he had tofu in his fridge and he
said it was vegetarian so just for
context
um yeah and so the question for all of
you guys is so let's say an alien race
car I think that's a very resounding
thing about not having a vegetarian diet
I can't understand anybody
it's okay
um
you're in Germany and they speak German
sorry and if you follow the question was
yeah so the follow-up question is let's
say an alien race comes to our planet
and they come to you in real life we're
talking you guys on the stage
um and they say I give you all the power
you can have but you can only do good
things and you can't harm any people or
animals
but you can do whatever you want so
yesterday you can get Trump arrested but
you can't kill him and
Ben
what do you guys do what would be one of
the most important things
for you so I would just I would just
I wouldn't kill Ben I just made him
disappear
yeah I just want to clarify that again
she could have all the power but you
can't use it for evil yes so you can do
whatever you want for people and the
planet and try animals but you can't
harm anyone what we were talking about
backstage about how we would solve world
hunger so that would be a good start
one way or another I lose Trump for sure
but that's an evil man so yes she is can
you just record them
send it to him
[__]
well that's a start anyway getting rid
of him what would you do for good and
World Peace
yeah world peace I
it's a really deep question I'm going to
try to answer it quickly and not too
deep I would like people to be able to
listen to one another
and to be able to forgive one another
what do you say
World Peace
I was you missed the part where you were
cast as a cello
[Applause]
okay
I love you
it's been right
foreign
I'm so sorry
but all right try and get us off
no I want to say thank you very much you
guys you were a great place Make some
noise for you
all right
Samantha Carter Amanda Chapman
foreign
[Applause]
I knew you were expecting Rick also and
he is just finishing up his photo ops
but I didn't want you to have to wait
before he gets here
oh man it's so great to be back here
thank you so much for having us and um
hi
thank you
um I don't know do we want to just start
with some questions or what oh I guess
we do there's a bright light on you and
you're ready Sweet let's do it hi oh
first of all I forgot my black shoes so
I apologize
and
[Applause]
uh pretty
all those things it kind of helped her
become Canada's leading
um
director I almost said female director
but that's a property these days right
she's really smart and knows what she's
doing and everybody knew she would
succeed Beyond
our wildest imagination
I think it's awesome thank you
thank you Greg thank you
and then I had a quick story question as
well and it's about the filming
locations
um
I know the British Columbia the four is
there
you feel there a lot and I was wondering
of course your professionals and but if
you ever feel like oh oh like nothing
Sports again
it was very boring for you guys yes I
mean not this big gorgeous Green Valley
and mountainous Forest again
a hundred times so yeah it became a bit
of a joke that all the planets in the
universe had evergreen trees in really
good air
and and now like we have a Sam doing we
got to film in and we had a bunch of
different locations that don't exist
anymore because of urbanization but uh
the forest
Forest is always there and it was it was
wonderful to work but we went we drove
up mountains and shot in this beautiful
pristine forests it was amazing but yes
the entire universe looks like British
Columbia
[Applause]
stay close together for body heat and
one of the crew members said well you
know if you guys were serious about body
heat you wouldn't be wearing any clothes
soon in the series for that me thanks
[Applause]
which goals did you have for those
teenagers and did you meet all of them
which titles goals dogs
I was like dolls
um
[Music]
my goal was to be an actress and my goal
was to be a director
winning yes
[Applause]
[Music]
I on the other hand
strive to be a juvenile delinquent
winning
um no I actually wanted to be a forest
ranger I wanted to work in the forest
mountains and have a little thumbs up
and then the stilts and you know call
girls and stuff
no I wanted to work with animals and and
conservation stuff I didn't know it was
conservation then but trees and bushes
and shrubbering
and that kind of stuff I I just leaned
in that direction
you ended up working in forests for a
long time
[Applause]
maybe a little bit more fun for you so
could you tell us the best piece of
advice you've ever been given can be
about work life all sorts of things but
can you do it in an accident of your
choice
one word to say for that
you're asking for performance that's
unfair indeed
um
my parents always said to me and I'll do
my dad don't ever be rude don't be rude
be kind don't be rude because people
don't like rude people
[Applause]
eat your veggies period
[Music]
[Applause]
should be
also really become thank you for being
here
big fan of Stargate sg1 and of MacGyver
and also a big fan of the movie and my
question so the starting to read and my
question kind of things into that
because one of you had a rule that was
already presented in the movie and one
of you wasn't
and I want to know know what do you
think was the scarier part to act out
I know I know
I it was easy for me I just you know
they didn't want me to be Kurt Russell
couldn't make my hair do that
and he smoked and so we got rid of both
of those things and you seek what you
see today
it looks good yeah
nice trial
all right
[Applause]
I was lucky because my character wasn't
in the movie so she could be whatever we
made her
become
but I think it might be scarier to
actually try to
fill the shoes and change the shoes of a
character that already exists and is
loved so you know that a side note to
this
of notion
Kurt Russell came on and said yes one
time
I met him once before with
um he and Molly were lit by where I
lived in the California Southern
California and I was back in the day
when I actually did exercise
was running my path up in the mountains
and the two of them came down with their
dog and of course immediately unto the
dog you could just give it dirt could
and he came up to me he was a pretty
easy thing and just laughing me up and I
said God I love this dog look up and
it's already in a conversation with them
don't know it's them
Ram
any further questions no uh I can't tell
you what's happening with him because I
I don't know but Brad and I were very
good friends and we've certainly talked
about
if there were another star game to come
out that my involvement if he would like
me to direct it and be a part of it and
be in it to a degree and uh yeah yeah
I'm you know I
Stargate has been such a huge huge part
of my life and years too maybe
and the fact that you know we started
calling 25 years ago and we're still
here talking to all of you is like I
can't think of a better word but it's
I'm dog smack and so I'm so grateful and
so if it were to come back I would never
look that gift horse in the mouth I
would absolutely jump on board but as
for what's happening
Amazon owns MGM now
MTM has been owned by so many different
people so I don't I honestly couldn't
tell you but certainly Brad reached out
to me and said if it does would you do
it removed and I was like yeah
[Music]
um
is still involved because you need to
write a few years ago or a pilot yeah it
was great yeah so I don't know again I
don't know so I look forward to meeting
I will ask your contact person and wait
for the chocolate it's nice continuation
overall sort of running gank and it is
being started because I really wondered
that you guys were so friendly and all
the crazy stuff I witnessed for myself
you are doing and I said do these guys
ever finished one thing today because
there is so hilarious it was lot of fun
thank you thank you see you tomorrow
nice to see you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
you in the dark
because they're all here and this just
seems silly to stop can we do three more
questions or is there somebody else
coming on stage
sorry people where is it well tonight
should we ask one who will ask one more
question and then
one last question
hi Amanda hiring it's so great to see
you two on stage
my question is of your post activism
are you doing on the 3rd of June an
online event for mental health so
remember I think that's really awesome
and I just wanted to know how that came
about and if there are any further
events like that and for it are you
planning on any sea Shepherds humans are
going on a ship or anything else and if
there are no plans is there anything you
would like to do
well I'll just speak quickly to the
mental health so the companion and I had
a conversation over a year ago about
things that mattered to me and one of
them was mental health and part of it
was born of the fact that sci-fi fanned
them
is so incredibly supportive and
connected and so many people around the
world have made friends through my
experience through Stargate but
obviously through other shows and how
how essential that connection was
especially at times when people were
feeling really really horrible and so I
said I think that especially even the
last three years in the pandemic and
isolation and lack of connection and
events like this
that I thought it was just really
important to check in and make sure that
we were all okay because we're not all
okay I mean this new normal has been a
big adjustment and
as somebody who my eldest brother was
before he passed was paranoid
schizophrenic and I saw firsthand what
mental health how it affected families
community and so I just it's it's a
subject very near and dear to my heart
and I felt like it just I just wanted to
connect and just talk about it so that
it wasn't so taboo and so that we could
say like your beautiful comment up there
um before about how important
certain things can be to help keep you
grounded and keep you here
and I just uh it was just it's just a
Grambling it's an important topic to me
and I think it's really important that
we feel that connection and that's what
it was born of so
[Applause]
[Music]
well
um
I think this is gonna sound a little bit
negative
um
it's probably going to sound a lot of it
Angry
Sea Shepherd and Captain Paul Watson
part of the waves
of
Paul was essentially kicked out
Sea Shepherd wanted to soften their
image a little bit Paul had a reputation
for being quite confrontational
if you think ramming chips is
confrontation hi Don and he was
he was asked to leave
he is
um I love Paul
a lot but he has an ego
if you're watching this anywhere Paul
you do
but um
uh so he he has started the captain Paul
Watson Foundation
which is a separate entity from start
Earth Stargate
Seagate
procedure
Sea Shepherd is still thriving and
working their campaigns and stuff such
Paul just acquired his first ship
for his foundation and the soliciting
contributions like he did was was
starving but it's
you know what I mean
with Sea Shepherd but um
but it's kind of a I don't know how many
of you even know about Sea Shepherd and
Paul Watson's Foundation but
um it's it's kind of a tough
call like who do you do you donate to
both that would be ideal but
um
some people feel as though they've been
made to make a choice
um
and so far I've fallen on the on the
side of Sea Shepherd as the established
entity
I still don't know the details of what
their policy is
and what their platform is and
when they go out and have confrontations
Paul you all can pretty much figure out
what he's he's still about
which is fine it's worked in the past
but I think he's got to soften some
edges it turns people off some people
that excites and uh
I don't know what else to say about that
but I'll put a word in for both sides
because I'm I'm a chicken and a coward
but uh that's kind of what's going on
there the merchandise is much better and
see
meditations
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
do you think comes out in both of you in
your characters
both of my characters
both of you both Amanda and Richard
I don't know
and that's it
now I I references earlier about my own
self-assessment I've had a lot of time
off I think a lot too much of
but being very as rational objective as
I can be I'm not that great an actor so
I can't tap into a process or uh
a process and
so I base a lot of my action reaction
any internal work I do it's done as
richer
with the sheep's clothing on
wait I didn't mean sheep
acts
of clothing
um so that's you know you do see a lot
of my personality interwoven to somebody
else's words interwoven other people's
words
in a different costume
because of course I thought it was a
costume Jeweler
um
I think that Sam and I grew up together
and I've said this before but I think
that we came into our own as women
together uh
loyalty I think is something that is
really important to me and it was very
important to Sam a little bit of a sense
of humor and an earnestness that I have
always had an eagerness to please
why are you guys laughing
here
it's my sire my swear to God
I'm getting me in trouble with Mom
I think to me to be 100 honest it was a
very symbiotic relationship between Sam
and Amanda and I learned a lot from her
and I think I informed a little bit uh
of her but yeah
especially after 10 seasons we all kind
of
became our characters a little bit and
our characters became part of us I
learned to be a lot stronger because of
Sam
so yeah is that I feel very unfortunate
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]